Hey guys, we're about to do an episode of Smart List, are you guys ready? Are you ready? Coming in hot. My brain thinks too fast before my mouth. Are you just sliding us in here? Yeah. I'm sliding us in here because I just, I like the energy, I like the energy in my voice right now.
嘿，伙计们，我们马上要录一期SmartLess了，你们准备好了吗？准备好了吗？气势汹汹地来了。我的脑子转得比嘴还快。你这是在强行把我们塞进来吗？对。我把我们塞进来是因为我就是，我喜欢这种活力，我喜欢我声音现在的活力。
I like how fast I'm talking. I'm really excited for the episode. You guys on board to listen or what? Sean, sit down. Sorry. Just take a second. Sit back down. Here comes some smartness.
我喜欢我说话的速度。我真的很兴奋能录这期节目。你们准备好听了吗？还是怎么着？肖恩，坐下。抱歉。花点时间。重新坐下。高智商内容来咯。
Smart. Less. Smart. Less. Smart. Less. Smart. Less.
Smart。Less。Smart。Less。Smart。Less。Smart。Less。
Smart. Less. I don't want you to take this the wrong way, but can I ask you a question? Is that the part I'm going to take the wrong way or is it the question that's coming? Here's the question. In the last 12 hours, have you been chugging soy sauce? Boy, that's a pretty shiny glass house. You just clean those windows?
Smart。Less。我不想让你误会，但我能问你个问题吗？是我接下来要误会的那部分，还是即将提出的问题？问题是这样的。在过去的12个小时里，你一直在狂灌酱油吗？天哪，你还真是住在玻璃房子里呢。你刚擦过那些玻璃窗吗？
You fucking. But there's a lot of sodium in those hot dogs at the diner stadium. And especially the veggie dogs, which you know, my soft Hollywood ass eats. And then the. Of course you do. You cut the dog into a salad form. By the way, we've all seen your hot, hot saggy ass in Ozark. It's a nice ass.
你他妈的。但餐馆体育场的那些热狗里有很多钠。尤其是素食热狗，你知道的，我这个好莱坞软蛋经常吃。然后。你当然会。你把热狗切成沙拉的形式。顺便说一句，我们在《黑钱胜地》里都看过你那性感、下垂的屁股。那是个好屁股。
Yeah. It's, it's not funny. And then I had four bags of peanuts. Those come salted. But you know what? I'm. Did you really have four bags of peanuts? Yeah.
对。这，这不好笑。然后我吃了四包花生。那些都是带盐的。但你知道吗？我。你真的吃了四包花生吗？对。
But they're smaller this year. So it's really two. Oh, okay. That's what you tell yourself. That's a good story. You tell yourself. I love. I love.
但它们今年变小了。所以实际上算两包。哦，好吧。那是你用来自我安慰的说法。这是个好故事。你自己编的。我喜欢。我喜欢。
I love a. Bag of nuts. I was going to do a nut joke and. Bag of nuts. You say it. You love chugging nuts. Yeah. You know, in my mouth and a bad nice bag of nuts.
我喜欢。一包坚果。我本来想讲个关于坚果的笑话，然后。一包坚果。你说吧。你喜欢狂灌坚果。对。你知道的，在我嘴里塞上一包好坚果。
Yeah. But it's cheap. This is a cheap joke. It is cheap. Yeah. You know, you know what I was going to. You know what was driving me crazy? I was thinking about, uh, you drive into the thing was like driving.
对。但这就很低级了。这确实很低级。对。你知道，你知道我本来要。你知道是什么快把我逼疯了吗？我在想，呃，你开车去那个地方就像开车一样。
We had never talked about driving on the show. I had a guy yesterday park his car half in a parking spot. And so that his right bumper was almost an inch from my door. So I couldn't get back into my car. And I was like, Hey man, and I, and I see this woman. I go, look at this parking job. And this woman's on the other side of me going to get in her car and she goes, Oh, I thought you were talking about mine because my parking is not great because she had in fairness.
我们以前在节目里从来没聊过开车。昨天我看到一个人把车停在两个车位中间。导致他的右保险杠离我的车门只有差不多一英寸。所以我进不去自己的车了。然后我就想，嘿，兄弟，然后我，我看到一个女人。我说，看看这停车技术。这个女人在我的另一侧准备上车，她说，哦，我还以为你在说我呢，因为我的停车技术不太好，因为她当时说句公道话。
She did tend to the parallel parking with no other cars around her and bail because it wasn't great. But I love watching somebody bail from a parking with all that extra space. She actually looked over at me when he was, and I was sitting there with the kids were waiting for food sitting outside this restaurant and she looks at me and I kind of went, but just kind of like that. Non-judgment, like as much as I could, right? So anyway, so then I go to look, find the guy and he's picking up like five pizzas and
她确实是在周围没有其他车的情况下尝试侧方停车，然后就放弃了，因为停得确实不怎么样。但我喜欢看别人在一大片空地旁边放弃停车。当他停的时候，她实际上看了我一眼，我当时就坐在那儿，孩子们在餐馆外面等着吃的，她看着我，我大概就这样，就那种表情。没有评判，尽可能地表现出来，对吧？所以不管怎样，然后我去找那个家伙，他正在拿大概五份披萨，然后
I go, Hey man, is this your car? You've parked in front of my door. So again, he goes one second and I go, No, no, no, no, you're waiting for, he goes there. Just one second. The other, the other people parked there. I'm, no, I'm just picking up my phone one second and I'm like, Oh, am I on your time now? Did you say that?
我说，嘿，兄弟，这是你的车吗？你停在我车门前面了。所以同样的，他说等一下，我说，不，不，不，你不，他在等，他说这就一秒钟。其他人停在那里的。我说，不，我只是在拿我的外卖，一秒钟就好，然后我就想，哦，现在我是得按你的时间来吗？你这么说了吗？
So I wait for this guy. You didn't say it. I didn't say that. That's something I would do, but you think it. I say it and it's, it's a problem though. And I'm the pizza guy. So he, and you're the pizza guy. So as he comes back and I'm like, I'm believe, I go, this guy is so inconsiderate and this
所以我等这个家伙。你没说。我没说。那是我会做的事，但你心里这么想。我说出来了，然后，这就成问题了。我是那个披萨小哥。所以他，而你是那个披萨小哥。当他回来的时候，我就像，我简直不敢相信，我说，这人太没眼力见了，然后这个
woman goes, she goes, I love smartness. I listen to smartness every day and I go, well, this is going to make it into the show. So you're going to hear. So you're out there, whoever you are. She's a very nice lady. So the guy comes back with the pizzas and it comes back and he finally, and he's like, these other people parked on the other side of me and he was like Italian or something because you kept them in there and parked on the other side and I couldn't get it in
女人说，她说，我喜欢SmartLess。我每天都听SmartLess，我说，好吧，这肯定会播进节目里的。所以你等着听吧，不管你是谁。她是个非常好的人。然后那个家伙拿着披萨回来了，他回来了，他终于，他说，其他人停在我另一边，他可能是意大利人还是什么的，因为你把他们夹在里面，停在另一边，我根本没法
anyway. And I'm like, Oh, okay. Yeah. So anyway, so you're good. Are you good now? Are you all loaded up? Can I load my car now? Yeah.
不管怎样。然后我就想，哦，好吧。好吧。所以，行了？你现在好了吗？你都装好了吗？我现在能把车装上了吗？对。
With myself. You know what it is? You know what it is? It's when people do shit and they have zero consideration for the world around them, which is a lot. It's like people with their driving again. It's like blinkers. Yeah.
带着我自己。你知道这是什么吗？你知道这是什么吗？这就是当人们做某些混账事时，对周围的世界完全零考虑，这种情况可太多了。就像人们开车那样。就像转向灯一样。对。
It's like, put your fucking blinker on man. I know. That just happened to me yesterday. Our guest, I bet you he wishes people would use their blinkers because this would impact him directly because of what he does because he rides motorcycles. Well, let's just say this. He's a real life action hero and that his job and Arnold Schwarzenegger and I said real life.
就像，打个他妈的转向灯吧，老兄。我懂。我昨天刚遇到这种事。我们的嘉宾，我敢打赌他肯定希望人们能打转向灯，因为这会直接影响到他，因为他的职业，因为他骑摩托车。好吧，我们这么说吧。他是个现实生活中的动作英雄，这就是他的工作，阿诺德·施瓦辛格，我说的是现实生活中。
Oh, I said, wait, oh, wait, I can, I can pick it off the laugh right. This is a guy who turned pro and what he does at the age of 14, I'm pretty sure. He dominated for about a dozen years of being the number one at what he does. He's the first person ever in competition to pull off a 900. What they call a nine at the 1999 X games. He is one of the most recognizable people in the world. He is. He's got all sorts of foundations.
哦，我说，等等，哦，等等，我可以，我可以从笑声中挑出来，对吧？这是一个在14岁时就成为职业选手的人，我相当确定。他在大约十年的时间里一直统治着这个领域，成为他所从事领域的头号人物。他是有史以来第一个在比赛中完成900度转体的人。他们在1999年的X Games极限运动会上称之为“9”。他是世界上辨识度最高的人之一。他是。他有各种各样的基金会。
He's now got a new podcast that is going out to the whole world. He's an incredible. Tony Hawk talks about shit. His name is Anthony Hawk. Tony Hawk. Tony Hawk. Come on. There it is.
他现在还有一个面向全世界的新播客。他是一个不可思议的。托尼·霍克在胡扯。他的名字叫安东尼·霍克。托尼·霍克。托尼·霍克。来吧。就是这样。
What's up? Hello there. Tony, welcome to the podcast, man. Yeah, nice to meet you. So excited to have you here, man. I've just, I'm so. Thank you. Such a huge fan of what you do.
怎么了？你好呀。托尼，欢迎来到播客，老兄。对，很高兴见到你。很高兴你能来，老兄。我只是，我太。谢谢你。我是你所做的事情的超级粉丝。
I'm available. You're one of those people. I watch what you do when I go every single time. I could never do that. I could never do that. Nothing you do could I do. Is that the name of your new podcast? Tony Hawk talks about shit.
我随时待命。你是那种人。我看着你做的事情，每次我都会想。我永远做不到这一点。我永远做不到这一点。你做的任何事我都做不到。那是你新播客的名字吗？托尼·霍克在胡扯。
No, that's not the name of your new podcast. What is the name of your new podcast? It is called Hawk versus Wolf and it is with my friend, Jason Ellis, who had a very good run of success on SiriusXM and he and I started actually on SiriusXM together about 15 years ago and both left there eventually and decided to come back together and tell our stories. It's fun. He is hilarious and has been in some of the craziest situations and I have my share of stories too.
不，那不是你新播客的名字。你新播客的名字叫什么？它叫《霍克对决沃尔夫》，我和我的朋友杰森·埃利斯一起主持的，他在SiriusXM卫星广播上取得了非常巨大的成功，我和他大约15年前实际上是一起在SiriusXM开始起步的，后来两人都离开了那里，并决定再次聚在一起讲述我们的故事。这很有趣。他超级搞笑，经历过一些最疯狂的情况，我也有我自己的故事要分享。
Wow. First of all, what Sean is chomping at the bit. He loves people's crazy scenario situation stories more than probably anything and he's hoping that involves you being hurt, but let me just ask you this Tony and you've been asked this a million times and I'm sure you're bored, but take us back. You started as a pro skater when you were a teenager. What was that? What was that moment of like you're a kid who skates, you know, grew up in Southern California
哇。首先，肖恩已经迫不及待了。比起其他任何事情，他可能更喜欢听别人疯狂的情境和故事，他希望这其中包含你受伤的桥段，不过让我问你这个，托尼，这个问题你已经被问过一百万次了，我确信你已经听烦了，但把我们带回过去吧。你十几岁时就开始当职业滑板手了。那是什么感觉？那种作为一个喜欢滑板的孩子，你知道的，在南加州长大
and all of a sudden what you're doing it professionally. What was that? You're kind of in quotes, right? Because there wasn't a bunch of money in that business at the time, right? Right. Yeah. It's more along those lines. It was kind of like being deemed a professional hula hooper.
然后突然之间你开始以它为职业。那是什么感觉？你其实是“加了引号”的，对吧？因为当时那个行业里并没有什么大钱，对吧？对的，没错。更接近这种情况。这有点像被封为一个职业呼啦圈选手。
There were no contracts being offered to me. I basically entered a, I filled out an entry form to a competition and instead of checking amateur I checked professional and that was it. I was pro. I moved up a class in competition and I was competing for $100 first place prize, but I was 14 and a hundred bucks, you know, I was on my way to buying a moped. So it felt awesome because it was, you know, in terms of like where I, what I was doing in the world I was in, that was the, that was the top of the line.
没有人给我提供合同。我基本上是填了一份比赛的报名表，在上面我没有勾选业余选手，而是勾选了专业选手，就是这样。我升级到了更高的比赛组别，我在为100美元的第一名奖金而战，但我当时14岁，100美元，你知道的，我正准备买一辆轻便摩托车。所以感觉太棒了，因为，你知道的，就我在世界上的位置以及我在做的事情而言，那就是顶峰了。
But I never imagined it'd be a career. Not at all. And so you made me turning pro wasn't a huge deal in terms of the purses and stuff initially, but you are like going to competitions with that just Southern California where you instantly kind of around the country, around the world. At that moment in skating, it was almost exclusively in Southern California. Okay. Yeah.
但我从没想过这会是一项职业。完全没有。所以你转为职业选手最初在奖金方面并不是什么大事，但你当时是去参加比赛吗，仅仅是在南加州，还是你马上就去全国各地、世界各地了？当时在滑板界，几乎完全是在南加州。好吧。对。
The doggedown ZYZ area had kind of ended and skating was starting to sort of implode. And so the only skate parks around were in Southern California. And so I was, my dad was driving me to all of them. So was there a sort of, was there a moment in that industry where stuff blew up? And I'll bet you were either a part of that or solely responsible for that or certainly in attendance at whatever event that was where, where things went, oh my God, this is now, you could definitely sense it was the start of sort of the X games or what helped out with snowboarding and did a bunch of things coalesce at a certain moment and the industry
Dogtown Z-Boys那个时代已经结束了，滑板运动开始有点崩溃。所以当时仅存的滑板公园都在南加州。所以我是，我父亲开车带我去所有的滑板公园。那么在那个行业里，有没有这样一个时刻，事情突然爆发了？我敢打赌你要么是其中的一部分，要么是唯一的罪魁祸首，或者至少参加了那个让事情发生天翻地覆变化的活动，当时人们会想，“天哪，现在这，你绝对能感觉到那是X Games极限运动会的开始，或者是什么推动了单板滑雪的发展”，是不是很多事情在某个特定时刻结合在了一起，然后这个行业
became white hot. Yeah. I think that's the perfect storm was the X games was on the rise in popularity in the late nineties. Our first video game was released in 1999 and all of those things happened at the right time and skating blew up in the early 2000s and got to a point where I never imagined. I never dreamed that we would be on television or be doing arena tours and it was wild. And it kind of, I mean, it has wavered a bit in popularity, but the foundation is set and
变得超级火爆？对。我认为完美的风暴是X Games在90年代末人气飙升。我们的第一款电子游戏是在1999年发布的，所有这些事情都在正确的时间发生了，滑板运动在2000年代初大爆发，达到了我从未想象过的地步。我从未梦想过我们会出现在电视上或进行体育场巡演，这太疯狂了。而且它有点，我的意思是，它的受欢迎程度有过一些波动，但基础已经奠定，
I feel like it's always going to sort of be there as a choice for kids to be doing it as readily as baseball or basketball. How much time do you spend thinking about pushing the sport forward in developing not only just new tricks because I mean, I think gravity will probably present the ceiling against that, but thinking about incorporating, you know, those frigging little those scooters like blades or those motorized skateboards or like, are you do you feel a burden to think about? Okay, what's next?
我觉得它总是会作为孩子们的一项选择存在，就像棒球或篮球一样触手可得。你花多少时间去思考推动这项运动向前发展，不仅是开发新动作——因为我的意思是，我认为重力可能会为此设定一个上限——而是思考如何将那些该死的滑板车、轮滑鞋或是电动滑板融合进来？或者说，你会不会觉得有一种负担，要去思考：“好吧，接下来是什么？”
And I've got to stamp this. I've got to drive it. I've got to keep the sport growing so it doesn't plateau out that do you feel a responsibility for that at all? I guess I do in a sense, but I don't, I think of it just more along the lines of fun and how do we continue to keep the awareness of skating or to broaden the reach of skating. But I can tell you, the Olympics are going to do that by default. Next month, skateboarding is making its debut in Tokyo 2021 Olympics.
“我必须盖上我的印记。我必须推动它。我必须让这项运动不断发展，这样它就不会陷入停滞。”你对这个有一点责任感吗？我想在某种意义上我确实有，但我不这么认为，我只是更多地从乐趣的角度去思考，以及我们如何继续保持对滑板的认知度或扩大滑板的影响力。但我可以告诉你，奥运会将默认做到这一点。下个月，滑板运动将在2020年东京奥运会上首次亮相。
That's so exciting. That's amazing. I would assume you're going to be there. Are you going to be a part of that in some capacity? I am going to be there. NBC has me doing interviews and wrap ups and things, but they haven't actually given me my exact job description yet. So I'm just excited to be invited because it's not easy to get to Tokyo to even be there
太令人兴奋了。这太棒了。我猜你会去现场吧？你会以某种身份参与其中吗？我会去的。NBC让我做采访、总结和一些事情，但他们实际上还没有给我具体的职位描述。所以我只是很高兴能被邀请，因为要去东京甚至只是去到那里都非常不容易
at all. Yeah. Maybe your job description is just go over there and be rad and be Tony Hawk. By the way, speaking of rad, it's a word I still use and I don't, I imagine you use it too. There's a lot of flak for using it. It's still okay to use rad, right? I feel like it's come full circle.
对。也许你的工作职责就是去那儿表现得很酷，做托尼·霍克本人。顺便说一句，说到“酷（rad）”，这是我依然在用的一个词，而且我猜你也在用。因为用这个词挨了不少批评。用“rad”还是可以的，对吧？我觉得它现在又是一个轮回了。
Like it wasn't cool and now let's, we're back in it. We're so back in it. You know what? Tony Hawk and I are back in it with the rad. Hang on, Jason. I'm still basking in the glow of- He has validated that. How do you feel? I feel like the clothing version of that is overalls.
就像它以前不酷了，现在我们又开始用了。我们太喜欢用了。你知道吗？托尼·霍克和我又开始用“rad”了。等等，杰森。我还沉浸在——他已经证实了这一点。你感觉怎么样？我觉得这就像是服装界的背带裤。
I would like to offer that as maybe something. I really miss wearing overalls. I wore that a lot back when rad was invented and which is short for radical, Tracy. And I would like overalls back in. So if you could maybe put that into the culture, I'd appreciate that. I don't know if I have that much pull. We can bring back rad. We can make it cool.
我想把它作为某种东西提出来。我真的很怀念穿背带裤的日子。在发明“rad”那个年代我经常穿它，也就是“radical”的简称，特雷西。我希望背带裤能回归。所以如果你能把这个带回流行文化里，我会很感激的。我不知道我有没有这么大的影响力。我们可以把“rad”带回来。我们可以让它变得很酷。
Overalls would be hard. Wait, Tony, what are you doing in New York? I'm here for our anniversary. My wife and I, we actually escaped the kids for the weekends. Yeah. You know what? By the way, Tony, you don't have to answer that. He's kind of grilling about his personal life, what he's doing with his wife.
背带裤就有点难了。等等，托尼，你在纽约干什么呢？我来这里是为了我们的周年纪念日。我和我妻子，我们实际上把孩子们甩在家里，过个周末。对。你知道吗？顺便说一句，托尼，你不用回答这个。他在盘问他的私生活，问他和妻子在做什么。
He's having a nice weekend alone. He wants to know what shows you're going to go see and I'll bet you're a big musical fan, right? Yeah. Are you? Do you have any great Broadway stories, Tony? Do you have any Broadway mishaps? I am working on a Broadway project.
他想度过一个美好的二人世界周末。他想知道你要去看什么演出，我敢打赌你是个音乐剧迷，对吧？对。你是吗？你有什么精彩的百老汇故事吗，托尼？你有什么百老汇的糗事吗？我正在做一个百老汇项目。
Of course you are. Are you being serious? Oh my gosh. Yes, I am. Starlight Express comes back. Not Starlight Express. Starlight Express. What is it?
你当然在做。你是认真的吗？哦，天哪。是的，我是。星光快车回归了。不是星光快车。星光快车。那是什麽？
Well, it will incorporate live skateboarding and music from Mark Mother's Ball, some of the diva library and that's a story of outcasts. Oh, all of a sudden Jason and Will are excited. Okay. Keep going. You know, that's, that's really cool. What a cool idea. How far along are you guys on that?
嗯，它将结合现场滑板和马克·莫里森（Mark Mothersbaugh）的音乐，还有一些Diva音乐库，这是一个关于边缘人的故事。哦，突然之间杰森和威尔兴奋起来了。好吧。继续。你知道，这真的很酷。真是个好主意。你们这个项目进行到哪一步了？
Yeah. And can John be part of it? Sorry. We, as far as we can get through COVID, but you know, we have, we have a, we have a book and we are working on music and everything. It's awesome. I mean, and Mark Mother's Ball is a genius. So it's been so fun listening or watching him come up with the stuff.
对。约翰能参与进来吗？抱歉。我们，能挺过疫情的极限就行，不过你知道的，我们有，我们有一个剧本，我们在制作音乐以及所有的事情。这太棒了。我的意思是，马克·莫里森是个天才。所以听着或看着他想出这些东西真的太有趣了。
Hey, Tony, how many kids do you have? How old are they and do they skateboard? Between my wife and I, we have six kids. Whoa. Lord. Five boys, all adult age now, all in college or graduated college and they all skate. That's amazing. I have a 12 year old daughter that she dabbles in skating, but none of her friends really
嘿，托尼，你有几个孩子？他们多大了？他们玩滑板吗？我和我妻子一共有六个孩子。哇。天哪。五个男孩，现在都是成年人了，都在上大学或已经大学毕业，他们都玩滑板。这太棒了。我有一个12岁的女儿，她偶尔会玩一下滑板，但她的朋友们其实都不怎么玩
do it. So she's not hooked on it the way they are. And do they feel any pressure to, to try to be as good as the greatest skateboarder of all time? I mean, how are they comfortable with that? Um, my oldest son, Riley, he's 28 actually, and he is a pro skater and is far better than I am in many ways. And the other ones, they don't, they don't take it as seriously.
所以她没有像他们那样沉迷其中。他们会有压力，想要努力成为史上最伟大的滑板手吗？我的意思是，他们对此感到自在吗？嗯，我的大儿子莱利，他其实28岁了，他是一名职业滑板手，在很多方面都比我厉害得多。其他的孩子，他们没有那么认真。
They enjoy it very much and they're all very good in their own right, but they're not trying to make a career out of it. And they, I think they just enjoy the, the sort of auxiliary opportunities that we get, especially if we're traveling, one of the first stops always is whatever skate park is in the area. Right. Now, whenever I've seen you over the years, you always, you know, because of your line of work, you always get to dress however you want.
他们非常享受滑板，而且凭他们自己的能力都玩得很好，但他们并不想把这当成职业。而且我觉得他们只是享受我们获得的那些附属机会，特别是如果我们去旅行的话，第一站通常总是当地的滑板公园。对。这些年来，每当我看到你时，你总是，你知道的，因为你的工作性质，你总是想穿什么就穿什么。
You're like right now and you're in a hoodie, you're skating, you're in shorts or whatever. It's always just super cash. Have you ever had a job where you actually had to wear like a suit or some kind of anything with buttons, any kind of uniform? Have you ever learned how to use a button? I don't know how to tie a tie. If that's what you're getting at, is that true? That is true.
就像你现在这样，穿着连帽衫，你在滑板，穿着短裤或者别的什么。总是超级休闲。你有没有过一份真正需要穿西装或者任何带扣子的衣服、任何制服的工作？你学过怎么系扣子吗？我不知道怎么打领带。如果你指的是这个的话，是真的吗？那是真的。
Wow. Wow. I have one tie in my closet. It's pre-tied and I loosen it and then I tighten it. That is okay. And if anybody ever on ties that you're screwed, right? Oh, it's bad. Yeah.
哇。哇。我的衣柜里有一条领带。它是预先打好结的，我把它放松，然后把它系紧。那还好。如果有人把那个结解开了，你就完蛋了，对吧？哦，那就糟了。对。
It's bummer. I didn't really know how to tie a tie until I started doing the rest of development. And then I had to tie a tie every single morning for, what, a few years and- Is that true? That is true. Yeah. What about you, Sean? You any good with the tie?
真遗憾。我直到开始做Rest Development之前都不知道怎么打领带。然后我不得不连续好几年，每天早晨都系领带——是真的吗？那是真的。对。你呢，肖恩？你很擅长系领带吗？
Yeah. Look at me. Yeah. Of course you are. This is the first time Sean has been wearing a baseball hat in 19 years. I know. My hair is so good. To answer your question, the only real job I have was being a paper boy as a kid.
对。看看我。对。当然了。这是肖恩19年来第一次戴棒球帽。我知道。我的头发太棒了。回答你的问题，我唯一真正的工作是小时候当过送报童。
That's a bike and a front basket and long tosses. Yeah. I did it on a skateboard. Oh, did you really? I did it on a skateboard. It's hilarious. I did. Yeah.
那需要一辆自行车、一个前车筐和长距离投掷。对。我是踩着滑板送报的。哦，真的吗？我是踩着滑板送报的。这太搞笑了。真的。对。
Now, I'm sorry to digress for a second, but I'm a goofy foot. That means I'm a lefty Tracy. Same. Now, when I'm kicking, getting speed up, the kicking foot needs to go to the back of the board when you're done kicking, right? Not the front of the board. I think I'm doing it wrong and I think I'm teaching my daughter to do it wrong. Yeah.
现在，抱歉岔开一下，我是右脚在前（Goofy foot）。意思我是个左撇子，特雷西。我也是。现在，当我用脚蹬地加速时，蹬完地后，这只脚需要放到滑板尾部，对吧？而不是滑板头部？我觉得我做错了，而且我觉得我教我女儿的方法也错了。对。
So what you're describing is what we call Mongo and you are pushing with your front foot, correct? Yeah. You're so Mongo, dude. And Mongo is not rad. No. It's not rad, dude. It's not rad at all, dude.
所以你描述的就是我们所说的“Mongo（前脚蹬地）”，你是用前脚在蹬地，对吧？对。你太Mongo了，老兄。而Mongo一点也不酷。不。这不酷，老兄。这一点也不酷，老兄。
You're so Mongo and so un-rad. So gross. Mongo's rongo. And if you want to get into the weeds, it's because you are pushing with your front foot and then when you put your front foot on the board, you have to readjust your back foot as well. Yeah. Yeah.
你太Mongo了，太不酷了。真恶心。Mongo就是Rongo（糟糕透顶）。如果你要深究的话，那是因为你是用前脚蹬地，然后当你把前脚放到滑板上时，你还得重新调整后脚的位置。对。对。
And there's a lot of adjusting happening. So a lot of things that can go wrong in that transition. Yes. And it's because you're insecure, right? It's because you're insecure and you have a lot of issues that you should deal with and you haven't dealt with because you're too Mongo in that. Mongo is a state of mind, right? Exactly.
而且有大量的调整动作。所以在那个转换过程中有很多地方可能会出错。是的。这是因为你缺乏安全感，对吧？这是因为你缺乏安全感，你有很多心理问题需要处理，但你一直没有处理，因为你在那方面太Mongo了。Mongo是一种心态，对吧？没错。
Yes. I'm going to fucking kick your ass, aren't I? Mongo. Guys, I can't make it to, I can't do the podcast today. I'm feeling a little Mongo. I'm too Mongo. I'm too Mongo to do this. Oh my God.
是的。我他妈要踢你的屁股，对吧？Mongo。伙计们，我今天不行了，我今天录不了播客了。我感觉有点Mongo。我太Mongo了。我太Mongo了，做不了这个。哦，天哪。
Now, what do you have to say to the kids out there about elbow pads, knee pads, and helmet all the time or just when you're doing something that's carrying a lot of speed or you're dealing with the ramps, the half pipes, things like that? I mean, if you're just going down the street, you're getting from place A to place B, what kind of pads are we talking about? Any at all? Well, I recommend pads for beginners, absolutely. Helmet can save your life.
那么，对于外面那些孩子们，关于护肘、护膝和头盔，你有什么想说的？是一直都要戴，还是只有在速度很快的时候，或者在玩坡道、U型槽这些设施的时候才戴？我的意思是，如果你只是顺着街道滑行，从A点到B点，我们说的是哪种护具？完全需要吗？嗯，我强烈建议初学者戴护具。头盔能救你的命。
And especially when you're skating the bigger ramps and things, I mean, that's just pure survival. And now, a word from our sponsors. I want to talk about, Tony, the guys know I love to talk about this. What's the worst injury? I know you're probably sick of talking about it, but I'm fascinated with stuff like that. Worst injury and how long did it take to get over? I broke my pelvis and it took me about six weeks to walk with a severe limp.
特别是当你玩更大的坡道之类的时候，我的意思是，那纯粹是为了生存。广告之后，马上回来。托尼，我想聊聊，伙计们都知道我喜欢聊这个。最严重的受伤是什么？我知道你可能已经厌倦了谈论这个，但我对这种事情很着迷。最严重的伤是什么？花了多长时间才恢复？我骨盆骨折了，花了大约六周时间才不再严重跛行。
How old were you? I think I was 37 or 38. How many times have you been to the emergency room? Over or under 15 times? Over. Oh, God. Oh, my God. Sean, you broke your pelvis when the Macarena came out, didn't you?
你当时多大？我想我37或38岁。你去过急诊室多少次？超过还是低于15次？超过。哦，天哪。哦，天哪。肖恩，玛卡雷那舞（Macarena）流行的时候你骨盆骨折过，对吧？
Because you just went so, you were so taken with the Macarena. I was so excited. And then what's the thing the kids do with the fists, shaking back and forth behind them and in front of them and behind them and in front of them? You resnapped it on that, I think, trying to learn that, right? Oh, that one. Yeah, yeah, yeah. What's that one called?
因为你太，你太迷恋玛卡雷那舞了。我太兴奋了。然后孩子们用的那个把拳头在身前身后、身前身后摇晃的动作叫什么？你学那个的时候好像又把它二次骨折了，对吧？哦，那个。对，对，对。那个叫什么来着？
Oh, flossing, yeah. Flossing. Jason, did you just get an email from 2017, what happened? So Tony, so you went to the hospital, dozens of you broke your pelvis and I like the way you had to think about it. You're like, I guess when I broke my pelvis, did you ever have like a big injury when you were a kid and your folks were like, dude, you got to stop skateboarding? They never told me to stop, but they were concerned because I got a pretty bad concussion
哦，Flossing（牙线舞），对。Flossing。杰森，你刚刚是不是收到了一封2017年的邮件，发生什么事了？所以托尼，你去了医院，你骨盆骨折了无数次，我喜欢你思考这件事的方式。你就像是，我猜当我骨盆骨折的时候，你小时候有没有过一次严重的受伤，当时你父母对你说：“老兄，你得停止玩滑板了？”他们从来没让我停下来，但他们很担心，因为我早期受过一次相当严重的脑震荡，
early on, knocked out my front teeth, and I remember I had a string of injuries all in within a year when I started getting serious about skateboarding. And then they started sending me insurance forms in the mail as if I were an elderly, high risk patient. No way. So and my parents said, oh, this is because you've been to the hospital so many times. But I was lucky in that they knew I was going to keep doing it. What happened for you when the moment when you're like, oh, this, I'm going to march
门牙都被撞掉了。我记得当我开始认真对待滑板时，我在一年内连续受了一连串的伤。然后他们开始在信箱里给我寄保险表格，就好像我是一个老年高危病人一样。真的假的？所以我的父母说，哦，这是因为你去了太多次医院。但我很幸运，因为他们知道我会一直坚持下去。当你有那么一刻，心想：“哦，这个，我要昂首挺胸地走到我父母面前说，
right up in front of my parents and say, basically, how do you like me now? I told you it was going to work out and things are working out for me and start getting on board because look what just happened. Was it a check? Was it a contract? Was it an award? Honestly, I got really lucky. My parents were always supportive of it, even when the outlook was bleak.
基本上，现在你们怎么看我？我告诉过你们这行得通，事情正在朝好的方向发展，开始支持我吧，因为看看刚刚发生了什么。”那是一个支票？是一份合同？还是一个奖项？老实说，我很幸运。我的父母一直都很支持我，即使在前景暗淡的时候也是如此。
And so they were as excited and surprised as I was when I was making money and I literally bought a house while I was a senior in high school. Wow. You bought a house while you were in high school. Yeah. In my senior year, my dad cosigned for it because I was not 18 yet because he was encouraging me to obviously put my money away because he could see that it kept coming and I was not really concerned with saving it.
所以当我也开始赚钱时，他们和我一样兴奋和惊讶，我在读高中最后一年时甚至真的买了一栋房子。哇。你还在上高中时就买了一栋房子。对。在我高三那年，我爸爸为我作了担保，因为我当时还没满18岁，因为他显然在鼓励我把钱存起来，因为他能看出钱源源不断地进来，而我其实并不关心存钱的事。
That is officially rad. Yeah. And I know I've read things about you that you're an entrepreneur. You have a bunch of different businesses. What are they? Well, mostly my skate brand, Birdhouse skateboards. Yeah. We have one here at the house.
这绝对是太酷了。对。我知道我读过关于你的报道，说你是个企业家。你有很多不同的生意。都是些什么？嗯，主要是我的滑板品牌，Birdhouse skateboards。对。我们在这栋房子里就有一个。
Oh, thank you. My 12-year-old has one. You're the reason we've been going for almost 30 years now. God, that's amazing. And then we have a foundation, the skate park project for public skate parks in their served areas. Hot clothing is a clothing brand that my siblings and I started for, well, it's basically supposed to be skate and surf clothing for kids.
哦，谢谢。我12岁的孩子有一个。多亏了你，我们已经运营了快30年了。天哪，太惊人了。然后我们有一个基金会，叫“滑板公园项目”，为服务不足的地区建设公共滑板公园。Hawk Clothing是我和我的兄弟姐妹创立的一个服装品牌，嗯，它基本上是为孩子们设计的滑板和冲浪服装。
That's so cool. But turned into something bigger than that. Do you have a lifelong battle with security guards? When you see a security guard, because they're the people who are trying to keep you from skating everywhere, do you see a security guard as your back arch up a little bit and you're like, here goes my enemy? I endured them through the years. Obviously.
太酷了。但后来发展成了比这更大的东西。你是不是与保安进行着一生的战斗？当你看到保安时，因为他们是那些试图阻止你在各地滑板的人，你看到保安时，你的后背会不会有点紧绷，然后心想：“我的仇敌来了？”这些年来我忍受了他们很多次。很显然。
I'm more of a skate park or ramp skater, so I'm more about skating in designated spots. But you would be surprised at the anomaly of the stuff that I can get away with sometimes when I get recognized. Of course. I'm sure. Yeah. You could just jump into somebody's backyard and start skating and then they came out and then they see it's Tony Hawk and then they're like, oh, yeah, it's cool.
我更多是一个滑板公园或坡道滑板手，所以我更倾向于在指定地点滑板。但你会惊讶于我有时在被认出来后能逃过惩罚的奇特情况。当然。我敢肯定。对。你只要跳进某人的后院开始滑板，然后他们走出来，看到是托尼·霍克，然后他们就会说：“哦，没问题，酷。
No problem. Just keep at it. Do you need me to take the water out of this pool? Just give me a minute. Yeah, I'm sorry. Do you want something to drink? Can we film you? We went to an apartment complex where they had an empty swimming pool that we heard about
继续玩吧。需要我把这个泳池里的水抽干吗？给我一分钟。”对，我很抱歉。你想喝点什么吗？我们可以拍你吗？我们去过一个公寓大区，那里有一个我们听说过的空游泳池，
and we got there and they were very eager to kick us out. And then one of the guys recognized me and then they welcomed us and made barbecue for us. That's awesome. That's true. That is awesome. I want to know, how old were you and what was the moment where you kind of looked around and said, wait a minute, I can blow this thing out into a corporation much bigger than just
我们到了那里，他们非常急切地想把我们赶走。然后其中一个人认出了我，接着他们欢迎我们，还为我们做了烧烤。太棒了。真的。太棒了。我想知道，你当时多大，是在哪个瞬间你环顾四周，然后说：“等一下，我可以把这门生意扩大成一家比仅仅在滑板界发展大得多的公司，”扩展到你创办的所有这些业务中？有没有一个人让你眼前一亮，对你说道：“嘿，如果你聪明的话，你就应该分流出去做所有这些事情”？或者有什么事情启发了你，让你觉得：“等一下。”
skating into all of these businesses that you started. Was there a person that caught your ear and was like, hey, if you were smart, you'd kind of like branch out and do all that stuff? Or was there something that inspired you that happened? You were like, wait a minute. I think now is the opportunity to hit while the iron is hot. I think it was in the early 2000s when suddenly my name was synonymous with video games and people started saying my name as more of a company or a brand than me personally.
“我觉得现在是趁热打铁的好机会。”我想那是在2000年代初，当时我的名字突然成了电子游戏的代名词，人们开始更多地把我的名字当作一家公司或一个品牌，而不是我个人。
That was when I realized that it had a broader reach and that I could probably have a lot more opportunity and maybe create other direction or other businesses through skateboarding. And that's when I started the boom of Huck Jam, which was an arena tour that featured skateboarding BMX and motocross. And it was all stemmed just from that sort of recognition factor that I had. That's really cool. Does your skateboarding talent translate similarly to a snowboarding talent or a surfing talent? A little.
就在那时我意识到它有更广泛的影响力，我可能可以获得更多的机会，并也许通过滑板开辟其他方向或其他业务。也就是在那时，我开启了Huck Jam的热潮，这是一个体育场巡演，主打滑板、小轮车和摩托车越野赛。而这一切都源于我当时所拥有的这种认可度。这真的很酷。你的滑板天赋能同样转化为单板滑雪天赋或冲浪天赋吗？有一点。
I have been surfing almost as long as I've been skating, but I don't like big waves. I don't like being held underwater by the sheer force of them. And snowboarding is maybe a little bit closer for me. I've been doing that since, well, since actually it was invented. I wonder if, like, does Kelly Slater skate as well as you surf? Or does Sean White skate as well as you snowboard? I'd love to see that smackdown between the three of you guys. Yeah, that's a good idea.
我玩冲浪的时间几乎和玩滑板的时间一样长，但我讨厌大浪。我讨厌被它们的巨大力量按在水下。单板滑雪对我来说可能稍微更接近一些。我玩这个的时间，嗯，实际上是从它被发明出来开始。我在想，凯利·斯拉特（Kelly Slater）滑板滑得有你冲浪一样好吗？或者肖·怀特（Shaun White）滑板滑得有你单板滑雪一样好吗？我很想看你们三个人之间的巅峰对决。对，这主意不错。
I'll tell you, Sean White is an excellent skateboarder. He is a pro skateboarder as well as a pro snowboarder. Kelly on skateboard is not so much. Yeah. But he can play golf. My God. Yeah. Oh yeah.
我告诉你，肖·怀特是一个出色的滑板手。他既是职业滑板手，也是职业单板滑雪手。凯利玩滑板就不太行了。对。但他会打高尔夫。天哪。对。哦，是的。
He's a great dude. We should play with him. Wait, Tony, do you play golf? No. Okay. Well, we're going to start you real soon. The other thing is my son just finished my 12 year old, 12 and a half year old. He just did his first, he just did a week of surf camp and he did really great and he
他是个绝佳的家伙。我们应该跟他一起打球。等等，托尼，你会打高尔夫吗？不。好吧。我们很快就会让你开始学的。另一件事是，我儿子刚刚结束了我的12岁，12岁半。他刚完成了他第一次，他刚参加了一周的冲浪营，他表现得非常棒，而且
had the same thing though. He was just like, there were a couple of days where there was a pretty big swell. Now I'm going to start using verbiage that Tony and I know because we're both kind of ran. Yeah. Kind of talk slow for me and Sean. Yeah. So there's a pretty sweet swell.
不过他也遇到了同样的情况。他只是觉得，有几天海浪涌浪相当大。现在我要开始使用托尼和我都知道的术语了，因为我们俩都挺酷的。对。为我和肖恩说慢一点。对。所以有一个相当不错的涌浪。
Anyway, he got, after the first week he got, they gave him the word for best wipeout because he took a board to the nose. Sorry. He was cleaning something? You said wipeout? No, no. He took a board to the nose. He was not awake.
不管怎样，第一周结束后他得到了一个“最佳翻船奖”，因为他的鼻子挨了一记冲浪板。抱歉。他在清理什么东西？你刚才说翻船？不，不。他的鼻子挨了一记板子。他当时不清醒。
I know. Jason's such an inside cat. He was cleaning something, something fell on him so he swelled and we were, we were out. They were kind of barreling. Well, okay. So here's the deal. So we're, anyway, the point is he's surfing and he took the thing to the nose and I understand that thing about surfing, I didn't surf my first time until my thirties and sometimes
我知道。杰森真是一个室内猫。他在清理某样东西，有什么东西掉在他身上，所以他肿了，然后我们，我们出去了。他们有点像在管状浪里。好吧，所以情况是这样的。所以我们在，不管怎样，重点是他在冲浪，然后他的鼻子挨了一下，我懂冲浪的那种感觉，我直到三十多岁才第一次冲浪，有时候
when those waves get big, I'm like, yeah, I'm scared of being held down by a huge wave. That kind of bums me out. I like a lot of the other stuff, but that thing really freaks me out and also the water tastes like shit. Yeah. There's that. But, you know, maybe we can put a little, we can put a little stevia in it to cut the salt.
当那些海浪变大时，我会想：“是的，我害怕被一个巨大的浪按在水里。”那真的让我有点沮丧。我喜欢其他很多事情，但那件事真的把我吓坏了，而且海水尝起来像屎一样。对。还有那个。但是，你知道，也许我们可以加一点，我们可以加一点甜菊糖来盖住咸味。
Have you guys, Jason and Sean, have you guys ever served a little stevia? Yeah, man. No. Are you kidding me? When? When? When? When?
你们俩，杰森和肖恩，你们俩冲浪时加过一点甜菊糖吗？对，老兄。没有。你在开玩笑吗？什么时候？什么时候？什么时候？
I mean, I'm bored of it now. A lot. No, I do. I know you skateboarded. I once stood up on a board just long enough, and it's just been the one time, but long enough to go, oh, wait a second. The waves get smaller once you stand up. I did a lot of boogie boarding when I was a kid and of course the waves are at their
我是说，我现在对这个感到无聊了。经常。不，我做过。我知道你玩过滑板。我曾经在一块板上站起来足够长的时间，而且就这一次，但足够长到让我说：“哦，等一下。”一旦你站起来，海浪就变小了。我小时候玩过很多趴板冲浪，当然海浪处于它们的高度极限，
max height because you're always on your belly. But once you stand up on something, you're like, oh, I'm already six feet. So a six foot wave is, you know, I'm looking at right in the eye, so it's fine now. But that just happened the once. I'm remembering, Jason, you talking about, and correct me if I'm wrong, but hearing Tony talking about skating as a kid is reminding you of you with your skateboard on the bus in Woodland Hills. Is that ringing a bell?
因为你总是趴在肚子上。但一旦你站在某个东西上面，你就会想：“哦，我已经六英尺高了。”所以一个六英尺的浪，你知道的，我正视着它，所以现在没问题了。但那只是发生过一次。我在想，杰森，你刚才说的，如果我记错了请纠正我，但听到托尼谈论他小时候玩滑板，让我想起了你小时候在伍德兰希尔斯的公交车上带着滑板的情景。这让你有同感吗？
Yeah. I did, I did skate quite a bit when I was a kid living in the valley and when I had to get myself to auditions, I would jump on the, on the bus and ride it into downtown and then I'd have to skate a bunch of blocks to my audition. So I'd have my little skateboard and my headshot, my resume and a Manila envelope just skating down in Hollywood Boulevard at 12 years old and, you know, just trying to make a living man while you were, you know, figuring out how to flick boogers in elementary school punk. So you're OG.
对，我小时候住在山谷里时确实玩了不少滑板，当我不得不自己去试镜时，我会跳上公交车，坐它去市中心，然后我得滑好几个街区去试镜。所以我带着我的小滑板、头像照、简历和一个马尼拉信封，12岁时在好莱坞大道上滑行，你知道的，只想在老兄你还在琢磨如何在小学里弹鼻涕的年纪里谋生。所以你是OG（元老）。
Jason, you are OG. Oh, he's OG. Yeah, man. Back when it was, they were plastic boards with big, dumb, ugly wheels, you know, and only one tail on that thing. I don't believe you're on a plastic board. I don't believe you're that way. Yeah.
杰森，你是OG。哦，他可是OG。对，老兄。回到那个年代，那都是塑料板，带着又大又丑的轮子，你知道的，上面只有一个尾端。我不相信你玩过塑料板。我不相信你有那么老。对。
Yeah. It bent in the middle. It was, but well before wood was invented. Those skinny ones. Those real skinny ones. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
对。它中间会弯曲。那是，不过那是在发明木头之前。那些细长的板子。那些真正细长的板子。对。对。对。
Sean, have you ever skated? Did you ever skate at all? I did. I had a skateboard when I was little, but, you know, I tried it once or twice and wiped out and I was like, well, that doesn't feel good. So why do it? Yeah. Why put yourself through it?
肖恩，你玩过滑板吗？你以前玩过滑板吗？我玩过。我小时候有一个滑板，但是，你知道，我尝试了一两次然后摔了个狗吃屎，我想：嗯，这感觉不好。那为什么还要玩？对。为什么要让自己受罪？
Why put myself in that position to just wipe out again and hurt myself. I didn't understand. And then back in the red wagon. Right. Yeah. And then back. Screw this skateboard. And I've had Tracy pull me all around the neighborhood.
为什么要把自己置于那种再次摔倒并伤害自己的境地？我不理解。然后坐上小红车。对。对。然后。去他的滑板。我还让特雷西拉着我在整个街区到处跑。
Tony, what's your, what's your least favorite thing, a sort of thing that's out there about skating, like some sort of cliche or something that that's always bummed you out or just feels really inorganic. You're like, ah, that's not, um, well, I think that there, there were a lot of stereotypes about skating or skaters that they were just stoners or outcasts or problematic. And I think that it was just more that they were looking for something else. You know, they, they were not, they didn't fit into team sports with like, that's how I discovered it.
托尼，你最讨厌关于滑板的什么事情，比如某种陈词滥调，或者某种让你觉得很沮丧、很不自然的东西？你心想：“啊，那不是，嗯，”好吧，我觉得过去有很多关于滑板或滑板手的刻板印象，认为他们只是瘾君子、边缘人或者有问题的人。而我认为这更多是因为他们在寻找别的东西。你知道，他们，他们不适合像——这就是我发现它的方式。
I didn't really feel like I fit into team sports and, and I found this, this tribe of misfits that were very artistic, very creative. Um, and the whole idea that skaters are, are just trying to be, uh, punks is more because they didn't have any place to skate. So they skated on public property and hence the whole security guard issue and, um, and I feel like when you look deeper into it, you see that skaters are disciplined. They're creative. They're responsible.
我真的觉得自己不适合团队运动，然后我发现了这个由充满艺术感、富有创造力的乌合之众组成的部落。嗯，滑板手只是想成为朋克这个观点的存在，更多是因为他们没有地方滑板。所以他们在公共财产上滑板，因此才有了整个保安的问题，嗯，我觉得当你深入了解时，你会发现滑板手是很有纪律的。他们极具创造力。他们有责任感。
I mean, most of my friends are dads and they skate when they can and, you know, they pay mortgage and just have regular lives. Given that skating is so sort of simplistic, the physics of it, just a board and some wheels under it, um, it could have started like literally back when the wheel was invented. Um, do we, is there an agreed upon start of skateboarding? Like who invented the skateboard? Do we know? We already make fly in 1957, right?
我的意思是，我的大部分朋友都是爸爸，他们在有空时滑板，你知道的，他们要还房贷，过着普通的生活。鉴于滑板是如此简单，它的物理原理，只是一块板和下面的一些轮子，嗯，它其实早在轮子被发明的时候就可以开始了。嗯，我们，对于滑板的开始有没有一个一致的说法？比如是谁发明的滑板？我们知道吗？我们在1957年就开始飞了，对吧？
I'll tell you what, that was, that movie was a huge boost for skating in the eighties. For sure. Yeah, I'm sure. Massive. I'm sure. Yeah. Um, no, it's, it's, it's always hotly debated of how it started. Um, the, the general consensus is that someone took a two by four and nailed roller skate
跟你说吧，那部电影对八十年代的滑板运动起到了巨大的推动作用。肯定的。是的，我敢肯定。太巨大了。我敢肯定。是的。嗯，不，这项运动是怎么开始的，一直争论不休。嗯，普遍的共识是，有人拿了一块木板，把旱冰鞋的支架和轮子钉在上面。那是哪一年，或者在哪里，现在已经不可考了。哇。那真是，呃，我觉得这里面有拍电影的素材，你提到，你提到了一群当爸爸的朋友，他们现在还在滑板，你到哪个阶段、什么年龄看着他们会觉得，哦，也许是时候该放弃这玩意儿了。是的，这里的界限是什么？
trucks and wheels to it. What year that was or where that was is undetermined. Wow. That would be, uh, I smell a movie in that you mentioned, you mentioned like a bunch of your friends that are dads that still skate at what point and what age do you look at them and go, oh, maybe it's time to cop on that thing. Yeah. What is the cut off there?
是骨质疏松吗？当你知道，如果你只是绊到了一小块石头，然后从板上跳下来，浑身骨头都要碎了，那大概就是那个年纪吧？那会是70岁吗？等我到了那个年纪再告诉你。太好了。我想我是那个最爱试水温的人。是的，我的意思是，当你看到那些大型制药公司的广告时，你会发现，
Is it, is it osteoporosis when, you know, if you just catch a small rock and you jump off the board, everything snaps, that's probably the age, right? And what is that 70? I'll let you know when I get there. Yeah. That's great. I think I'm the one testing the water is the most. Yeah, I mean, you don't see that when you see those big pharmaceutical ads for like,
你知道的，关于稀释血液或者别的什么，你从来没看到他们在滑板，对吧？就像他们只是在散步之类的，我猜当你，是的，完全正确。嗯，托尼，有没有哪项其他的运动是你所仰慕的，要么是你一直想尝试的，然后心想，天哪，你知道的，那才是终极的运动，你知道的，你对它有着无上的敬意？有没有哪项是特别的？嗯，我对那些冲巨浪的人有着极大的敬意。我的意思是，在生存方面，这看起来太吓人了。
you know, heart thinning stuff and whatever, you never see them skateboarding, right? Like they're on walks and stuff, I guess when you're, yeah, exactly. Um, Tony, is there another sport that you look up to that either you've always wanted to try and you're like, gosh, you know, that is just, that is the ultimate, you know, you have the ultimate respect for that. And is there one specific one? Um, I do have a huge respect for the people who ride giant waves. I mean, that just seems so terrifying in terms of survival.
对，对，对。莱尔·汉密尔顿可能为我们所有人都做好了心理准备。好吧。是的。我的意思是，你知道的，当你，当你看到时，但我也觉得技术已经取得了很大的进步。
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Laird Hamilton's got, uh, got nerds for all of us probably. Okay. Yeah. I mean, it's just, you know, when you, when you see, but also I feel like the technology has come a long ways.
所以很明显，他们为应对紧急情况装备得更好，但只要去到那里，就知道——我随时都可以滑坡道，任何尺寸的坡道都可以，但我知道自我摔倒后，那个坡道不会压在我身上。对，对，对，对。是的。
So obviously they have, they're better equipped for emergencies, but it just to go out there and to know that like, I'll skate a ramp any day, any size ramp, but I know that that ramp is not going to crash down on top of me once I fall. Right. Right. Right. Right. Yeah.
就像莱尔·汉密尔顿，他有点，他也有点与众不同。就像你，就像他有点走自己的路，在冲巨浪方面创造了属于他自己的东西。对。是的。而且他，他算是开创了这方面的很多先河。我没说错吧？还是说我对的？不，绝对是的。
Like Laird Hamilton, he's kind of, he's kind of an outlier too. Like you, like he kind of did his own, like he's created his own thing in big wave surfing. Right. Yeah. And he, he kind of pioneered a lot of that. Am I wrong about that? Or am I right about that? No, absolutely.
而且他在安全领域生活的高度，是我见过的任何人所无法比拟的。太酷了。托尼，你平时，你听什么类型的音乐？或者你有没有最喜欢的乐队，或者是某种你常听的音乐类型？哦，还要告诉我们你最喜欢的颜色和你的星座。嘿，老兄。你怎么不稍微深入挖掘一下？这可是你的嘉宾，看在上帝的份上。
He, and he lives in a different realm of safety than anyone else I've ever met. So cool. Tony, what kind of, what kind of music do you listen to? Or do you have like favorite bands or a certain type of music that you would listen to? Oh, and then tell us your favorite color and your fucking astrological sign. Hey, man. Why don't you fucking dig a little bit deep? This is your guest for Christ's sake.
我想把他归入某种风格。我想看看他是不是那种，想知道他是不是喜欢南加州那种流行朋克乐队，比如Blink 182，这是否是他的菜，还是他更喜欢像我这样的老派独立音乐。和滑板有关的。是的。因为我们是同龄人。我们差不多大。
I'm trying to put him in a box. I want to see if he's like into like, want to know if he's into like Southern California, kind of like that sort of pop punk bands, like the Blink 182's, if that's his deal or if he's more old school indie like me. Skater related. Yeah. Cause we're the same age. We're roughly the same age.
是的。我会说更偏向老派朋克，你知道的，比如The Clash、Circle Jerks、Black Flag那类音乐，因为。性手枪。性手枪。是的。我的意思，那是当我成长时，滑板公园里的试音音乐。那是我的所知与所爱，而且迪沃（Devo）也在循环播放的名单里。
Yeah. I would say more older punk, you know, like The Clash, Circle Jerks, Black Flag, that kind of stuff because. Sex pistols. Sex pistols. Yeah. I mean, that, that, that was the soundcheck to the skate parks when I grew up. And that's what I knew and loved and Devo is heavily on rotation.
是的。马克把他们划掉了。就是这样。我们马上回来。现在回到节目中。托尼·霍克，就像托尼·霍克滑板、电子游戏以及你生活中的一切，这些在体育界都是广为人知的。人们最不知道的一点是什么？
Yeah. Mark them out of the spot. There we go. And we will be right back. And now back to the show. What is the thing like Tony Hawk, Tony Hawk skating and the video games and everything about your life is, is out there in the world of sporting. What is the thing that people are like, I didn't know.
就像百老汇音乐剧，人们会说，等等，你正在制作一部百老汇音乐剧。这挺酷的。还有其他类似的事情，让人觉得，等等，什么？我小时候拉过小提琴。哦，太棒了。我简直是为了滑板而放弃了它。哇。因为我的音乐老师告诉我，我必须二选一。
Like the, the Broadway musical, people are like, wait, you're working on a Broadway musical. That's pretty cool. Is there anything else like that that people would be like, wait a minute, what? I used to play violin when I was a kid. Oh, that's amazing. I literally gave it up for skating. Wow. Because my music teacher told me that I had to choose one or the other.
哇。而且，你怀念它吗？我的确怀念。是的。在当时，这两种职业哪一个更有收入潜力，其实真的很难抉择。对。我的意思是，我觉得无论选哪一个，无论选哪一个，都是为了追求荣耀。
Wow. And, and do you miss it? I do miss it. Yes. And at the time it was really kind of a toss up what had the best income potential between the two careers. Right. I mean, I don't think either one, either one was, was, uh, we're choosing glory.
嗯哼。你有没有因为小提琴老师逼你放弃小提琴而生她的气？有一点吗？我能感觉到一丝怨恨。有一点。是的。我觉得我本该为了好玩继续拉下去的，但我听了她的话，你知道你能做什么。这也许是一个好方法，可能会有宣泄作用，也是一个好方法来摆脱
Uh-huh. Were you mad at your violin teacher for making you give up the violin a little bit? Is there a little, I sent some resentment. A little bit. Yeah. I feel like I should have just kept playing for fun, but I listened to him and you know what you could do. And this is a good way to maybe it might be cathartic and good way to kind of get over
那就是找出他们在哪，你的小提琴老师，去买下他们的房子，然后一等房屋交易完成，就把房子拆了，然后痛斥他们说，这是你的责任，这是你自找的。你逼我这么做的。你知道的，如果你重新捡起来，你还能马上弹奏吗？或者不行？我试过了。不，这不容易。你喜欢古典音乐吗？你会听那些东西吗？
that is find out where they are, your violin teacher, go and buy their house and then as soon as it closes, tear down the house and berate them and say, this is your, this is on you. You made me do this. You know, if you picked it up again, could you play right away or no, I tried. It was, no, it was not easy. And do you like classical music? Do you listen to that stuff?
不太会。但是，我想如果我要重新捡起它，我会试着只翻弹一些老歌，比如The Clash和性手枪。是的。不，如果你，但如果你，如果你把车开到一个红绿灯前，你正踩着滑板，你看起来挺酷的，而且非常有型，突然你停下来，旁边有个家伙坐在家用车里，独自听着古典音乐，你会不会觉得，真是个书呆子。
Not really. But I, I think that if I were to pick it up again, I would try to just cover old songs like clash and sex pistols. Yeah. No, if you, but if you, if you rolled up to a, to a stoplight and you're on your skateboard and you're pretty cool and you're very rad and all of a sudden you pulled up and there's some dude in a family car and he's playing classical music by himself, would you be like, what a nerd.
我指的是杰森。等等，老兄。完全不会。不。我太太是古典音乐的超级粉丝。所以有时我上她的车，放的就是那些音乐。嘿，你在和这些视频游戏动画师开设计会议时，有没有遇到过什么尴尬的时刻，比如对他们大发雷霆，说“不，老兄，我滑板不这样”
And I'm talking about Jason. Wait man. Not at all. No. My wife is a huge fan of classical. And so sometimes when I get in her car, that's what's blasting. Hey, have you had any, any embarrassing design sessions with any of these? These video game animators about hammering them that, no dude, I don't skate like that
或者“我的脸看起来不那样”？还是说你真的会在你的风格上对他们严加审讯？你在意这些视频游戏对你外貌的准确性吗？你在意你的某个特定动作技巧，他们是否能做到准确无误吗？我想这可能是我现在参与制作视频游戏时最主要的工作，就是保持动作的真实性，因为他们已经弄清楚了滑板是如何运作的，包括动作图形、地点等等。
or my face doesn't look like that. Or do you really grind them on, on sort of on your style? Do you care about the accuracy of your likeness and any of these, you know, are you, are you a stickler about a certain, a certain part of your technique that, that you like them to get right? I think that that's probably my biggest job through doing video games now is, is keeping it authentic because they've already figured out how skateboarding works, motion graphics locations and things.
所以实际上，我只需要介入并说，不，这个豚跳滑行应该看起来是这样的。在这个技巧中，你应该这样接住滑板，是的，我会在这些细节上深究。你穿过那些动作捕捉的紧身衣吗？他可能已经穿过上百万次了，对吧？对。很多次。
So really, I just need to, I just need to step in there and say, no, this grind should look like this. You should be catching the board like this on this trick and yeah, I get into the weeds on it. Do you ever wear any of those motion capture suits and, and he's probably done it a million times, right? Yeah. Many times.
哦，哇。太酷了。自从第一款托尼·霍克游戏推出以来的二十多年里，你很可能对动作捕捉及其演变了解很多，对吧？是的。我早期做过，当时你必须穿上所有的乒乓球，并且设置了一百万个摄像头，那花了好长时间。我确实记得穿上那套衣服，那真的是，已经很尴尬了。
Oh wow. That's so cool. So much in the time since the first Tony Hawk game in the over, over 20 years that you quite literally probably know a lot about motion capture and the evolution of it, right? Yeah. I did it early on where you had to wear all the ping pong balls and, and have a million cameras set up that took forever. And I do remember getting in the suit that is, is so, it's, it's already embarrassing.
你会感觉非常脆弱，穿着紧身衣，上面贴满了小球，然后，当时的情况是，好了，做你最难的动作，开始。杰森，你从来没穿过粘着球的紧身衣做动作吧？不，完全没有，没有一堆球粘在我身上，不过摄像头，摄像头一直都在开着，最多有两个球，所以托尼，你在那些游戏里是玩得最好的吗？我想象会有些比赛，你在那些电子游戏比赛里会排在什么名次？我能应付自如，多年来我学到的是，如果有一款游戏是以你的名字命名的
You're feeling very vulnerable and the skin tight suit with all these balls and then, and it was like, okay, go do your hardest tricks and go. Jason, you never had to turn tricks with balls, right? No, not only, not a bunch of balls all over me, but cameras, cameras were always on and there was, there was a maximum of two balls, but so Tony, are you the best at those games? Like, I imagine there's some competitions that, how would you place in those, the video game competitions? I can hold my own, I've learned through the years that if you have a game with your name
你应该能够玩它，并且至少知道如何在不作弊的情况下通关。但有些人有更多的时间花在上面，他们打出的分数能达到我能做到的10倍，甚至有时候是100倍。我玩过很多次。我有过好几个版本的你的游戏，顺便说一句，我本来不想以此为开场白，但我有点像个游戏玩家，这是一款优秀的游戏，绝对优秀的游戏。嗯，我们重制了，如果我可以这么说的话，我们重制了前两部作品，所以它们在所有新系统上都有售，包括昨天刚刚发布的Switch。
on it, you should be able to play it and at least know how to complete it without cheating. But there are people that have a lot more time to spend on it and they get scores that are 10 times what I can do, 100 times what I can do sometimes. I've played it many times. I've owned a few versions of your games, just FYI, I didn't want to lead with that, but I'm a bit of a gamer and it's an excellent game, excellent game. Well, we remastered, if I may, we remastered the first two and so they're out on all the new systems, including Switch was just released yesterday.
哇，太棒了。干得好。太棒了。我要买。肖恩，我想我们刚刚猜到你今晚要做什么了。对。对。作为我的生日礼物。我就要去玩这个。
Wow, all right. Brad. Nice. I'm on it. Sean, I guess we just figured out what you're doing tonight. Yeah. Yeah, for my birthday. I'm just going to go.
哦，是的。生日快乐，肖恩。生日快乐。是的。非常感谢。谢谢。我弟弟给我发了一张我妈妈的玻璃义眼的图片，说“我和妈妈祝你生日快乐”。
Oh yeah. Happy birthday, Sean. Happy birthday. Yeah. Thanks so much. Thanks. My brother texted me a picture of my mom's glass eye and said, mom and I wish you a happy birthday.
他妈妈已经去世好几年了，托尼，以防你不知道的话。顺便说一句。好吧，肖恩，听着，肖恩，生日快乐。你爸爸和我，我今晚要和你爸爸喝一杯，今天是父亲节，他联系我一起聚聚，不过嗯。
His mom's been dead for a few years, Tony, just so in case you didn't know. Just FYI. Well, Sean, listen, Sean, happy birthday. Your dad and I are, I'm having drinks with your dad tonight, his father's day, and he reached out to me to hang, but um. That's cool. That makes sense. Oh, wait, Tony.
太酷了。这就对了。哦，等等，托尼。
Sorry. Sorry, Tony. We digress. Yes, your video game. I'm going to get it. I'm going to buy it. I'm going to win it. And then I'll text it to you.
抱歉。抱歉，托尼。我们扯远了。是的，你的电子游戏。我要买。我要买下来，我要赢通关。然后我会发短信告诉你。
I appreciate it. I'm getting it for you for your birthday. Thank you. Yeah. So, so Tony, and so you have this, this foundation where you create all this, you know, space for kids to use, blah, blah, blah, like, you know, by the way, I say blah, blah, blah, like a complete jerk. But yeah, what I mean is this is something that's.
我很感激。我要把它当成生日礼物买给你。谢谢。是的。所以，所以托尼，你成立了这个基金会，你在那里为孩子们创造了所有的活动空间，等等等等，你知道，顺便说一句，我像个彻头彻尾的混蛋一样说“等等等等”。但是，是的，我的意思是这是一件。
That's our mission statement. Actually, blah, blah, blah, skate parks, blah, blah, blah, I just mean that it's a lot. Yeah. You guys do a lot of stuff. I know, Angel. Yeah. I know.
这就是我们的使命宣言。其实吧，啰里啰嗦，滑板公园，啰里啰嗦，我的意思是内容真的很多。对啊。你们做了好多事情。我知道，安杰尔。对啊。我知道。
How long, what do you, do you see a sort of a breakthrough? Has there been a tipping point in terms of, okay. Just sounded out. Are you bored? Are you bored by what Tony's doing? I mean, Jesus Christ, Jason. No, plan the plane, bro. Check your notes.
花了多久，你觉得，你觉得会看到某种突破吗？有没有出现一个转折点，比如说，好吧。只是顺口一说。你无聊吗？托尼在做的事情让你觉得无聊吗？我是说，天呐，杰森。不，按计划来，兄弟。查查你的笔记。
I'm asking what is the goal? Is it, is it everybody skateboarding by 2050? Like that's, that's what I mean, like, are we all in a skateboard nation? No, the goal is more to have public skate parks in underserved areas, but also just so that anyone can go find a skate park in their area. We've been doing it 20 years and we've helped to fund over 500 parks that are completed now and we're coming into 900 that have been funded. And that's the work I'm most proud of.
我在问目标是什么？是，是不是到2050年所有人都在玩滑板？就像那样，这就是我的意思，比如说，我们是不是都成了滑板国家？不，我们的目标更多是在服务不到位的地区建立公共滑板公园，同时也让任何人都能在自己附近找到滑板公园。我们已经坚持20年了，我们已经资助完成了500多个公园，现在正朝着资助900个公园的目标迈进。这是我最引以为傲的工作。
I think if I had, if I had to choose a legacy of some sort, that would be it. That nut job Elon Musk said, Hey, why don't you hop on my jet and we'll go to the skateboard on the moon. Would you do it? Yeah, sure. Sure, I would. Wow. Yeah, who wouldn't?
我想如果我有，如果我必须选择某种传承，那就是这个了。那个疯子埃隆·马斯克说，嘿，你为什么不跳上我的喷气式飞机，我们去月球上滑板。你会去吗？对，当然。当然，我会去。哇。对啊，谁不会呢？
I would love to see. As long as it doesn't cost me anything. Yeah. By the way, I said, I said Elon Musk is a nut job. I don't mean, I mean that job in a great way. This guy's done incredible things. No, we all took it that way. Now, skate parks seem like a real easy thing to put into a city budget, right?
我很想去。只要不花我一分钱。对啊。顺便说一下，我说过，我说埃隆·马斯克是个疯子。我不是那个意思，我是以一种很棒的方式说他是疯子。这家伙做了不可思议的事情。不，我们都听得懂。现在，滑板公园似乎是很容易塞进城市预算的一项，对吧？
I mean, it's just basically, we need a bit of land, dig a hole and then shape it, pour some cement. I mean, it's about the cheapest thing you can do with civic engineering, I would imagine, right? Yeah, you would think it would be that easy. It's more the stigma in skateboarding and they think that the skate parks are somehow going to attract a bad crowd and be a bad influence. And that's usually the biggest barrier for getting skate parks approved.
我的意思是，基本上，我们只需要一块地，挖个坑然后塑形，倒点水泥。我的意思是，这大概是你在土木工程中能做的最便宜的事情了，我想是吧？对，你本会觉得那么简单。更多的是滑板运动带来的污名化，他们认为滑板公园不知为何会吸引不良人群并产生不良影响。这通常是滑板公园获批的最大障碍。
Because we approve projects or give them funding. That's usually the endorsement they need to get it sort of pushed through all the red tape. You know, it's funny, like you spend all your time, you talked about the stereotypes of like, you know, it's a bunch of stoners and whatever. But now given the environment we live in, can you imagine if you finally, if you announced that you were releasing a line of weed, all your critics would be like, see, see, he's just been waiting.
因为我们批准项目或提供资金。这通常是他们摆脱繁文缛节所需要的背书。你知道，很有趣，你花光了所有时间，你谈到了那些刻板印象，比如说，你知道的，全是一群瘾君子之类的。但现在考虑到我们生活的环境，你能想象吗？如果你终于，如果你宣布你要推出一系列大麻，你所有的批评者都会说，看吧，看吧，他一直在等这个。
We knew it. We knew it. We knew it all along. So we're like, this is really good for Ollie's. This type of weed is really good for doing trick, you know what I mean? This is like skate park weed. This is just like parking lot weed. After the skate park, wind down weed.
我们早就知道了。我们早就知道了。我们一直都知道。所以我们就觉得，这对奥利（Ollie）滑板很有好处。这种大麻对玩特技真的很有帮助，你知道我的意思吗？这就像是滑板公园大麻。这就像停车场大麻。滑板公园之后的放松大麻。
They all just have trick names. I'll bet you'd have a real decision to make if somebody approached you with just licensing just a weed brand. You can hand over fist now that it's all legal. You're 53. Come on, man. We're not going to judge you, dude. We're totally, I will defend you.
它们都用特技来命名。我敢打赌，如果有人带着单纯的大麻品牌许可来找你，你一定会面临一个真正的抉择。既然现在都合法了，你就可以数钱数到手软了。你都53岁了。得了吧，老兄。我们不会评判你的，伙计。我们绝对会，我会为你辩护的。
I will defend you. Just gummies, you know, not, not, not any flower, bro. Oh, does somebody like gummies around here? No, I hear that they're fantastic though. Skateboard shaped gummies. Yes. Oh, there we go. See, this guy's got so many good ideas.
我会为你辩护的。只要软糖就行，你知道的，不要，不要，不要任何花头，兄弟。哦，这里有人喜欢软糖吗？不，不过我听说它们棒极了。滑板形状的软糖。是的。哦，这就对了。你看，这家伙有这么多好主意。
It's unbelievable. There you go. That's it. Where do you stand on the, on the, on the skateboards with the motors on them? Does it make you cringe? No, no, I don't, it's, it's fine with me. That's the one I'll take. People say, you know, they're, they're all these, these purists that say, well, longboards
真是难以置信。这就对了。就是这样。你对那种带马达的滑板持什么态度？这会让你感到尴尬吗？不，不，我不会，这，这对我挺好的。那正是我要选的那种。人们会说，你知道的，有各种各样的纯粹主义者会说，长板
is not skateboarding because they're just transportation. And I say, hey, whatever gets you out there and on a skateboard and active is fine with me. Amen. Yeah. Yeah. A lot of people out there with complaints these days with stuff like that, you know, and everybody's taking positions and you know what my position is?
不是滑板，因为它们只是代步工具。而我说，嘿，不管是什么能让你走出门去玩滑板并保持活跃，我都觉得很好。说得好！对啊。对啊。现在外面有很多人对这种事情有抱怨，你知道的，每个人都在表明立场，你知道我的立场是什么吗？
Shut up. Yeah. Well, Tony, we've taken up way too much of your time, especially considering it's your anniversary weekend. Yeah. What an absolute honor to have you on the show. It's so nice. Honestly.
闭嘴。对啊。好吧，托尼，我们占用了你太多时间，考虑到这还是你的周年纪念周末。真是太荣幸能请你来节目了。真的太棒了。
You're incredible. Very nice of you to spend some time with us. Hey, I appreciate you guys having me on. It's a, I'm a huge fan. I listen to your show and all your other work as well. Thanks, man. We're going to listen to yours. Thank you.
你太不可思议了。你能花时间陪我们，真是太好了。嘿，我很感谢你们邀请我来。这是一个，我是你们的超级粉丝。我听你们的节目以及你们的所有其他作品。谢谢，老兄。我们要去听听你的节目。谢谢。
Good luck with your, with your podcast that's out now and, and maybe I'll see you over there at this week. Yeah. Let's go. We'll be here. All right. All right, pal. Thanks, Tony.
祝你的播客节目大吉大利，已经上线了，说不定这周我会在那边见到你。好。我们走吧。我们会在这里的。好啦。好啦，伙计。谢谢你，托尼。
See you guys. Bye, Tony. Bye. Bye, Tony. Thank you. Tony is a super nice fella. Yeah, he's really nice. He always, he always seems nice in the interviews that I've seen him on.
再见，各位。再见，托尼。再见。再见，托尼。谢谢。托尼真的是个超级好人。对，他真的很好。在我看过的他的采访中，他总是，他总是显得很好。
I'm so glad that I wasn't wrong with that. Yeah. He's great. He's always looked 15. And then when he said he had a 28 year old kid, how old the fella is, is Tony Hawk? I think he's 53. And he's still skating. That's what I'm talking about.
我很高兴我没有看错他。对啊。他太棒了。他看起来一直都像15岁。然后当他说他有一个28岁的孩子时，托尼·霍克到底几岁了？我想他53岁了。而且他还在玩滑板。这就是我要说的。
Yeah. He's still skating. He looks terrific. Doesn't he? Doesn't he look incredible? Well, by the way, one of the, the, for me, the funniest, one of the funniest lines from today's show. Oh, we're going to do highlights?
对啊。他还在滑板。他看起来棒极了。不是吗？他看起来是不是不可思议？顺便说一下，今天的节目中，对我来说最搞笑的，最好笑的台词之一。哦，我们要来回顾精彩片段吗？
Yeah. It was when Jason said, oh, I wasn't sitting. Hey, well, I wasn't sitting in class learning how to flick booger. By the way, and you know what I resent about that? I was sitting in class. I was teaching how to flick boogers. All right. I apologize.
对啊。就是杰森说，哦，我没有坐着。嘿，好吧，我当时没有坐在课堂上学习怎么弹鼻屎。顺便说一下，你知道我对那句话有什么不满吗？我当时确实坐在课堂上。我当时正在教怎么弹鼻屎。好吧。我道歉。
I apologize. Sean, I'm just, I moved out of the house at age 12, by the way. That's a true story. Moved or dismissed. I was moved out of the house and sent to all boys boarding school age 12. Sean, I cannot believe you're sharing some of your birthday with us. Why, why don't you just say, listen, Saturday doesn't work for me because it sounds like Sean, you and the Hawks need to coordinate next year and start doing your birth, your
我道歉。肖恩，我只是，我12岁就搬出家门了，顺便说一下。这是一个真实的故事。搬出去还是被赶出去。我是搬出了家门，12岁被送到全男子寄宿学校。肖恩，我真不敢相信你把你的生日和我们分享了。为什么，你为什么不说，听着，星期六对我不合适，听起来好像肖恩，你和霍克斯一家明年需要协调一下，把你们的生日，你们的
birthday and their anniversary together, like you and Scotty and the Hawks in New York. Yeah. Right. Just catching shows. How cool is it? How cool is it? Tony Hawk is his real name. I know.
生日和他们的周年纪念日合在一起过，就像你和斯科蒂还有霍克斯一家在纽约那样。对。没错。就是去看演出。多酷啊？多酷啊？托尼·霍克是他的真名。我知道。
That's one of the most people have to change their name to sound. I'm very excited about his, his skateboard Broadway show sounds very cool. I love that. When you said, what did you say? Starlight Express is coming back. Starlight Express. I hate to age myself here, but that was like a real eye opener, right? When they all those.
那是很多人为了听起来像而必须改名。我非常期待他的，他的滑板百老汇秀，听起来很酷。我很喜欢那个。当你问时，你说了什么？《星光快车》（Starlight Express）要回归了。《星光快车》。我讨厌在这里暴露自己的年龄，但那真是一个大开眼界的时刻，对吧？当他们所有人。
Yeah. Everybody was on skates. Roller skates. Yeah. The stage that they built for that. It was just a bunch of half pipes and tubes. I never saw it. I don't think it was a big hit, but I never saw it.
对啊。每个人都在滑冰。旱冰鞋。对啊。他们为那个搭建的舞台。那只是一堆半管和管道。我从没看过。我觉得它不是个大热门，但我从没看过。
Was it not? It was one of the biggest flops of all time. Is that true? Yeah. It was a huge flop. Yeah. Because they spent so much money on all the stuff you just described. Sean, how excited will you be to go and see the Tony Hawk?
不是吗？那是史上最大的票房惨败之一。真的吗？对啊。那是一次巨大的惨败。对啊。因为他们在你刚刚描述的那些东西上花了好多的钱。肖恩，你去看了托尼·霍克的演出会有多兴奋？
Yeah. Who would it be? I'd see that. By the way, that's what's cool is like seeing, seeing skateboarding live on stage every night. Like I can only imagine the set they're building must be massive. You see, now I could like Broadway. Now I could like a Broadway show if there's always the chance that they could crash and shut up.
对啊。会是谁呢？我会去看那个。顺便说一下，最酷的是什么，就像看到，每晚在舞台上现场观看滑板。就像我只能想象他们搭建的布景一定规模宏大。你看，现在我可能会喜欢百老汇。现在我可能会喜欢百老汇演出，只要随时都有可能发生他们会摔倒并且闭嘴的.
You know what I mean? The Cirque du Soleil, do you ever go in there and wait for some tragedy? Well, that's not Broadway. Well, you know, but it sounds like you like to sit there and wait for something terrible to happen. I do like some Broadway. It should be noted. I say that in jest.
你知道我的意思吗？太阳马戏团，你有没有去那里等待什么悲剧发生？好吧，那不是百老汇。好吧，你知道的，但听起来你喜欢坐在那里等待可怕的事情发生。我确实挺喜欢一些百老汇的。应当指出的是。我那是开玩笑说的。
There have been many shows that I've gone to that were great. Cats. You've been to a half dozen times, haven't you? I've never seen cats. Really? I never saw cats. Never. Lem is never.
我去过很多很棒的演出。猫。你去看过好几次了吧，对不对？我从没看过《猫》。真的吗？我从没看过《猫》。从来没有。《悲惨世界》也没有。
But you know, if you really want to go see that Tony Hawk show, you should be first in line to buy a ticket, buy a ticket, happy birthday, Shawnee, happy birthday, Shawnee. The next episode will be out in a week, wherever you listen to podcasts or you can listen to it right now early and on Amazon Music or by subscribing to Wondery Plus and the Wondery app. SmartList is 100% organic and artisanly handcrafted by Bennett Barbaco, Michael Grant Terry and Rob vistErf SmartList. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
但你知道，如果你真的想去看那个托尼·霍克的演出，你应该第一个排队买票，买一张票，生日快乐，肖妮，生日快乐，肖妮。下一期节目将在一周后发布，无论你在哪里听播客，或者你现在就可以在亚马逊音乐上提前收听，或者通过订阅Wondery Plus和Wondery应用程序收听。SmartList由贝内特·巴尔巴科、迈克尔·格兰特·特里和罗布·维斯特尔夫100%有机纯手工打造。这个节目目前还没有评论。点击剧本中的任意句子即可发表评论。